les membres du comité de défense des
habitants de la cité grenade a ajouté
mme rouillon à l'écouté de leurs avocats
raphaël constants une cité au coeur d'un
conflit avec la municipalité pour
obtenir des titres de propriété et le
désamiantage des maisons seize familles
une quarantaine de maisons en 1987 ses
habitants bénéficient d'un contrat de
location vente d'une durée de 15 ans
mobilisation après mobilisation l'a fait
depuis plusieurs mois devant la justice
qui s'est prononcée en mai dernier en
faveur des familles on avait saisi le
tribunal en référé pour demander a
ordonné à la mairie de réaliser les
ventes
le tribunal l'a acceptée alors que la
mairie s'y opposèrent et deuxièmement
nous le tribunal a ordonné des
expertises pour chiffrer le coût du
design otages et de la remise en place
des structures de ces maisons c'est à
dire qu'il est évident qu'on va acheter
on veut acheter on va acheter des
maisons qui doivent être réparés tenant
compte de l'expérience
c'est donc l'amiante qui inquiète par
dessus tout les habitants de cette cité
l'amiante présente dans ces plaques
colorés appelés fibrociment un danger
pour la santé interdit en france depuis
1996 robert kindu n'habite plus vraiment
sa maison suite au décès de son épouse
il ya quatre ans vous avez peur gérault
non seulement j'ai peur mais en plus il
ya des bouts de bois qui attaquent les
structures et comme on ne peut pas
déplacer les panneaux d'amiante
on n'a pas le droit de toucher comme ça
nous avons obtenu que la sous-préfecture
mettre en place une structure de travail
où il ya des représentants de la rs la
des halles et la dernière fois le cap
non la question de la prise en charge
des travaux ont pas anti pas en l'état
se pose
malheureusement ceux de noter c'est que
d'autres structures comme par exemple
officiellement cap nord est
officiellement la ctm n'ont jamais
répondu aux comités de défense sur le
soutien cette lutte et la prise en
charge de travaux une procédure de
désamiantage reste longue et très
coûteuse le tribunal a par ailleurs
ordonné au maire d'ajouts pas bouillon
de livrer les titres de propriété aux
habitants dans un délai de deux mois
au delà une abstraite de 100 euros par
jour pendant 1000 jours le maire n'a pas
souhaité répondre à nos questions pour
le moment une affaire qui est donc loin
d'être terminée